todos nós estamos assistindo a uma
escalada de preconceito e intolerância
no mundo todo
infelizmente também estamos assistindo
ao desenvolvimento igualmente crescente
de novas formas de abertura e
solidariedade em relação a outras
culturas
hoje já somos capazes de imaginar que
podemos aprender novas formas de
inteligência humana com culturas
indígenas aborígines tal estás budistas
hinduístas islâmicas judaicas etc
trabalhos como de boaventura de sousa
santos ou de viveiros de castro para
ficar em apenas poucos exemplos
encontraram ferramentas importantes de
compreensão dessas outras culturas a
ponto de começarmos a realmente
descobrir alguns elementos de sabedoria
de povos do presente e do passado que
possuem uma ciência muito diferente da
nossa
como a educação e os educadores podem
beneficiar se do conhecimento de outras
culturas
esse o tema que pretendo abordar aqui
ordinariamente estamos habituados a que
a razão é a nossa grande faculdade de
conhecimento e que além dela
possuímos algumas outras faculdades
emoção intuição imaginação que segundo o
senso comum são importantes no conjunto
da nossa vida mental mas não costumam
ser consideradas como faculdades de
conhecimento
eu vou apresentar para vocês uma
estrutura de faculdades que está baseada
no conhecimento medieval e mais
especificamente no sufismo que é uma via
mística muito antiga o que eu vou
apresentar já está muito diferente do
seu formato original mas é é com a ajuda
de vários autores modernos é eu arranjar
adaptei tudo pro nosso tempo
então eu vou combinar todos esses
elementos eu vou dizer que temos três
tipos de intuição três tipos de sensação
três tipos de pensamento e três tipos de
sentimento e com isso então eu vou ter a
intuição da alma intuição do corpo a
a missão do espírito sensação do corpo
sensação espiritual sensação na alma
pensamento espiritual pensamento da alma
pensamento do corpo sentimento da alma
sentimento do corpo sentimento do
espírito e isso é o que a gente conhece
como o zodíaco é uma ciência muito
antiga muito diferente da tecnologia
moderna e não tem nada contra mas é uma
coisa diferente que eu vou apresentar
para vocês aqui
isso aqui é uma realidade medieval aqui
nós temos também as faculdades que a
gente conhece essas duas formas
imaginação essas três forma emoção
essas quatro formam a razão e essas três
forma intuição
só que aqui nós temos uma coisa muito
diferente primeiro todas as faculdades
estão relacionadas entre si e todos são
igualmente sfax unidades de conhecimento
verdadeiro isto é emoção e imaginação
por exemplo são maneiras de se conhecer
e aprender tanto quanto as instituições
os pensamentos e as sensações e há
pessoas que aprendem mais facilmente por
meio de certas faculdades outras aprende
por meio de outras pessoas com as quais
a experiência emocional de estudo outras
com as quais o contexto a experiência
concreta são fundamentais
outras para quem uma explicação é o que
as faz realmente aprender a uma grande
discussão político jurídica atualmente
sobre igualdade e diferença e nos
principais problemas que essa discussão
aponta é que a gente faz tudo ao
contrário
por exemplo na escola a gente toca às
crianças como iguais e ensina a mesma
coisa para a classe toda e na sociedade
a gente trata por exemplo as mulheres e
os homens como diferentes pagando um
salário maior para os homens o ideal a
gente sabe seria que homens e mulheres
negros e brancos etc fossem tratados
como iguais e que na escola cada um
fosse tratado como completamente
diferente aqui nesses o dia com
encantado é como eu disse uma tradução
para o nosso tempo de uma estrutura
antiga
aqui nós temos uma ferramenta que
permite justamente tratar cada um como
sendo único e ao mesmo tempo
relacionando ficou todo sem perder sua
singularidade
se uma criança aprende mais facilmente
por meio de uma faculdade emocional
nós podemos começar dialogando com ela
por meio dessa faculdade e aos poucos e
trabalhando outras faculdades e é
possível fazer isso com a classe toda
conforme a gente vai criando programas
que contemplam diversos arranjos dessas
faculdades de modo que os alunos
participam contribuindo com as
faculdades e ao mesmo tempo uns
ensinando para os outros de um jeito
orgânico ou seja nós temos uma questão
muito importante para os educadores
podemos oferecer tanto as crianças
quanto os adultos caminhos diferentes
para aprender e no final chegará aos
mesmos lugares que alguns chegam
normalmente por meio das faculdades
racionais
só que isso representa uma grande
ampliação do nosso repertório e vou dar
um exemplo para vocês o que é o
pensamento corporal
esse aqui é o pensamento que funciona
como corpo no corpo todas as informações
são compartilhadas em tempo real num
sistema completo de feedback quando
aperta aqui tudo aqui sabe tudo se
conecta contudo a ponto de alguns
neurocientista dizerem que o cérebro o
corpo todo então esse tipo de pensamento
pensamento corporal é o que edgar morra
chama de complexidade ou que o de idade
escreveu como sendo combinações
infinitas na clausura de um conjunto
infinito
esse pensamento é o responsável pelo
pensamento em rede é internet é tudo que
foi holístico é a globalização é a
sustentabilidade é agrofloresta é a
medicina chinesa
trata se de um tipo de pensamento que
muitas crianças já dominam o espanto dos
seus pais
embora muitas vezes a escola possa
aparecer atuar de modo atrapalhar o seu
desenvolvimento
o nosso modo atual de ensinar matemática
por meio dessa faculdade mas como seria
por exemplo ensinar matemática de um
módulo logístico
alguns educadores já estão propondo isso
sem usar tecnologia que estou usando
aqui mas nós podemos propor aqui uma
multiplicidade de uma
multidisciplinaridade muito radical por
exemplo normalmente a gente acha que uma
coisa é a aula de geografia outra coisa
é a aula de ginástica
nunca trabalhamos com a mente em outra
com o corpo
o que a gente não pode aprender
geografia com o corpo ginástica com a
mente uma criança gosta de contar
histórias
outra gosta de ficar no seu canto em
silêncio imaginando coisas outra gosta
de conversar na aula para cada uma
dessas atividades cada criança tá usando
uma faculdade de conhecimento e se nós
agora fosse uns trabalhar a geografia
utilizando todas as faculdades como
ficar em silêncio num canto conta a
história vou conversar na aula pode ser
uma forma de aprender geografia
agora uma coisa muito interessante desse
conjunto de faculdades é que quando você
usa o conjunto todo e aprenda a fazer
combinações dentro dele você obtém
resultados de alta qualidade
você pode fazer uma tese por exemplo
usando conscientemente todas as
faculdades isso pode tanto facilitar o
seu trabalho quando se tornaram muito
mais completo e rigoroso
na verdade os grandes trabalhos já
possuem essa característica de usar
várias dessas faculdades em conjunto mas
nem sempre o seu autor está consciente
disso
ou você pode usar esse conjunto então
para projetar e construir uma casa
imagina um projeto de casa que leva em
conta tanto as abordagens e necessidades
diferentes
ou você pode criar uma coreografia ou
fazer um roteiro de filme como montar um
curso ou planejar sua vida ou melhor
ainda aprender a aprender com a vida sem
planejamento
outra coisa fundamental desse conjunto
de faculdade é a seguinte
grande parte dos desentendimentos entre
as pessoas vêm do fato obrigada se
sentiu tão grande parte dos
desentendimentos entre as pessoas vêm do
fato de que elas usam faculdades
diferentes para olhar o mundo e pra agir
nele quando a gente pode ser consciente
das estruturas que cada um tal
utilizando a gente pode perceber que
muito do que parecia uma imensa
discordância na verdade é uma diferença
de foco é isso é fundamental a gente tem
acompanhado inúmeras iniciativas
coletivas idéias incríveis gente com
excelente propósito e depois de um tempo
da briga entre as pessoas
e aí o trabalho se interrompe esse é um
grande mal do nosso tempo
quando a gente entende que pode abordar
as questões de maneira muito maneiras
muito diferentes então não é que a gente
passa a falar a mesma língua
não precisa falar a mesma língua mais
chatas negócio tem que falar a mesma
língua muito mais real e concreto é que
todos podemos falar diversas línguas e
nos entender de fato portanto esse
conhecimento permite que as pessoas
possam trabalhar efetivamente em
conjunto
eu vi isso acontecer de muitas maneiras
ao longo de 30 anos de pesquisa o que
mais me encanta é que quando as pessoas
se entendem
elas passam a criar juntas o que surge
daí é sempre algo de espantoso a beleza
esse é o uso da astrologia antiga como
instrumento pedagógico de enorme riqueza
ele pode ser visto como um caleidoscópio
de infinitas combinações o processo de
aprendizagem é incrível porque reúne o
singular e o total que é aquilo que é de
cada um o que é de todos ao mesmo tempo
o que nos permite tomar a forma que cada
situação exige e sermos profundamente
flexíveis uns com os outros
eu vou dar finalmente o último exemplo
nós estamos habituados com a idéia de
que nós possuímos uma identidade
acreditamos que é natural pensar que
cada pessoa possui uma identidade ou
personalidade adquirida desde cedo e que
é muito difícil mudar a gente pode só
melhorar alguma coisa ou outra mas a
gente não acredita que a gente pode se
tornar outra pessoa
sendo assim muitos de nós ficaram
surpresos ao descobrir que essa idéia
não é tão natural assim e que na verdade
ela só está presente desse modo na nossa
cultura ea partir de um certo momento na
história
outros povos em outros tempos não
pensavam desse modo
vejamos uma passagem extraído de um
texto do amado anppa tb é um grande
comprador de fígado jogador de culturas
africanas as pessoas da pessoa são
múltiplas na pessoa que ideia
interessante nós não temos uma
personalidade
temos inúmeras certa vez na turquia um
mestre sufi disse que um grupo que
estava ali acompanhando ele
ele disse assim as pessoas no ocidente
elas são engraçadas porque elas dizem eu
sinto muito mas eu sou assim quando na
verdade elas nem sentem muito e nem são
assim
além de não se pensar a partir de uma
identidade única ou fixa o homem antigo
também não se via de modo isolado como
indivíduo e como disse e volto e
benjamin o homem moderno está situado na
cidade enquanto o homem antigo
encontrava-se no cosmos no universo
inteiro
o mesmo um patê ba afirma o homem é um
universo em miniatura
o zodíaco das faculdades de conhecimento
é esse universo tudo está contido nessa
estrutura
agora há uma consequência que as pessoas
normalmente se esquecem de tirar dessa
ideia de que o homem eo universo em
miniatura ou micro cosmos como se dizia
antigamente é que o outro também é um
universo inteiro está diante de outra
pessoa é poder perceber os mais variados
usos de faculdades diferentes de
conhecimento e com isso já não se trata
apenas de respeitar o outro mas também
de aprender com ele
quando a escola foi um lugar em que
experimentamos que os outros são
universos inteiros cheios de modelos
próprios de conhecimento muito diferente
do nosso mas ainda assim perceptíveis
compreensíveis e comunicáveis e que cada
um pode ser sempre diferente talvez
possamos passar para um outro patamar no
qual ninguém tem mais nem interesse em
afirmar sua identidade
muito menos em impor o seu próprio
funcionamento aos outros
ao contrário todos saberemos que podemos
sempre mudar de forma e assumirmos
outras perspectivas e em vez de uma
escola que prepara para o mercado
teremos uma escola que prepara para o
outro então talvez possamos compreender
o que está dizendo o ib na árabe que é
um grande surfista em cuja obra esses
odiah kuta baseado e ele disse isso num
poema que é um dos seus poemas mais
famosos meu coração tornou se capaz de
qualquer forma o pasto para gazelas e
convento para o monge é um templo para
os ídolos e caba para os peregrinos e as
tábuas da torá o livro do corão
eu sigo a religião do amor por onde
forem seus caminhos
eis minha religião e minha fé
obrigado